oh
find out on this weekly v
if you do not love losing you lost
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what advice do you have for people when
it comes to to starting and especially
if they're met with negativity that
they're told no this is something that
you can't do learn to love to lose
like that's the whole punchline of
everything i believe in i love losing
here's why if i went at 16 to start a
charity to raise 40
000 and i didn't they were right
and i appreciate the experience of that
loss
[Music]
i adore losing because it's fair
you actually talked big game and you
were wrong you were naive
and young and you deserve that loss i
love
how you smile talking about losing i i i
you know
i'm sure if we look back at all my
content like i i'm
i'm not excited about winning like it's
why i even jumped in and said no no i
don't relate with that
right i relate with losing i like
underdogs
i like i can watch a sporting event that
i have no vested interest in
come in start rooting for the underdog
and then as the underdog is winning and
it looks like they're going to win
reverse back to rooting for the favorite
like i'm always rooting for whoever's
in the worst spot here's my thing if
anybody has
one that comes from your circumstance
you then have to acknowledge that it's
possible
people deploy things like luck of course
look you you were adopted
like i was born in the soviet union and
was able to immigrate to america during
this one small window
where out of hundreds of millions of
people you know 300 000 were able to
leave
during that era of course but
everything's of course like when people
like you're lucky i'm like you're lucky
you're born
400 trillion to one for you to be human
like where do you want to start this
luck game
like my big thing is that we the
internet
has created a world that far exceeds
the opportunities that we've ever seen
my big thing is do you want to dwell
and excuse your way through life or do
you want to
become accountable and optimistic your
way through life
to me accountability and optimism is
just
far more interesting and more
challenging
and more worthwhile and less regretful
when you're 90
than blame and excuses
and complaining and crying about it
ultimately because nobody's listening to
you cry
you think they are you you know maybe
your mom
maybe some other losing crying player
but like
like by the way and i hope everybody
hears me very clear
that doesn't uh dismiss the fact that
white males in america that are born
into high net worth organizat
organizations
families families don't have a
financial advantage i would argue
that from what i've observed a lot of
those
people end up losing because they
started with the advantage
and that is what made them soft or
uh insecure which led to their losing
even though they may have some more
stuff people like when i talk about this
people like
yeah well look at their stuff or look
how they live i'm like but they're not
happy
like do you want a mercedes and you're
deeply unhappy and doing cocaine to
escape your
problems or do you want a honda and be
pumped
and a lot of people answer mercedes and
unhappy because they're [ __ ] stupid
because they don't have that right now
and they think but like
you know like think about how many times
in life you said if i only
and then when you get there it's not as
delicious as you thought
all right so this morning uh g you know
you're at this time that g just got done
with this podcast and then the rest of
the day was just a lot of client stuff
that we weren't able to film
um so what i'm actually gonna do right
now is kind of walk you through his day
on instagram uh what he posted and kind
of why it was posted
um so we typically do like two videos uh
one in the morning one at night and then
two images in between
if you've got no if you guys notice we
consistently probably post like four
times a day
um the the monday morning video we
always try to make it like a very strong
piece of content
um and the one that we posted uh this
monday hit 1.3 million
uh we kind of knew it would hit over a
million just because we have some sort
of testing that we do with all content
before
we put it on his page so he can feel
confident about when we have a good
video
uh why we're posting it the next uh
thing that he posted was a twitter style
image
again this was also tested on another
platform we probably test like five to
ten images a day
and then pick the top two and put those
on instagram um so this is the one that
he picked
uh it's a it's a simple twitter style
bsu you guys have seen a lot of those
and we're seeing good performance out of
them so we're continuing to kind of try
to
ride that wave um and then this one was
kind of interesting
so uh in the afternoon he posted a throw
up picture of himself
so he's definitely still involved in
like what content we're posting
um it's not just us completely feeding
him everything he'll go rogue he'll post
his own stuff
and this one he's actually razzing on
drock which is always
something that he likes to do always
performs pretty well so if you guys
remember this one
he did that all himself found it shot it
posted it still very involved
and then later that night he's going to
roll to the
national title game takes a picture with
aj and we're going to run that footage
right now so hope you enjoy
that's a bit of the process and on to
the championship game
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
what's up weekly vlog uh weekly v
whatever the [ __ ] we're calling it it's
tuesday 1202. the reason i'm grumpy is
i was in the national championship game
last night uh then went out and
uh did some work with aj for vayner
sports
got home to the hotel at three was
supposed to have a
5 20 am alarm set
i swore i said it i'm pretty consistent
i've been doing this for over a decade
but
somehow it didn't happen hotel rings
it's 605 my flight's
done boarding at 6 45. i'm in the bed at
605
uh the airport is 27 minutes away
uh so i start you know obviously
rush the [ __ ] out of the hotel get to uh
the car
drive there's a [ __ ] accident uh
which
like kind of killed any of my prayers of
like him driving 100 miles an hour
which i didn't necessarily recommend but
uh and uh
somehow big shout out to clear if you
know clear in the airport
that [ __ ] thing saved me today
because there was no other flights there
was no other connecting
like i'd be in new orleans right now
with my whole day [ __ ]
uh got on the field after lsu one last
night that was ridiculous there's some
content
i'm sure you probably just saw it i
don't know how they montage this [ __ ]
now that we do weekly v but
if that was yesterday unless i'll let
you guys figure that out
now in a meeting with uh jim zane may
andy talking about segmentation within
community the texting platform
have a bunch of meetings today um
internal [ __ ] uh e-commerce capabilities
staffing issues co life
[Music]
what's good bro i'm about to do a
carousel i'm about to do a carousel post
on my instagram
with the guys that we've signed so far
so i'm going to screenshot
us talking on facetime
it'll look pretty bro look pretty bro
you better look pretty bro
come on man i gotta look pretty in
florida i know man hey listen
i'm so excited to announce man i'm gonna
i'm
i'm gonna text this uh these these uh
photos to you too if you wanna post
on your uh gram hit me up when you need
me okay
got you bro bye-bye what's up juan
johnson
who is that here that's juwan johnson we
just announced him
former penn state receiver transferred
to oregon
he got the game-winning first down in
the rose bowl this year uh
we just announced him really good wide
receiving prospect good get for
vaynersports
even better he's such a great kid and
two great programs like penn state and
oregon
all the kids in the locker room know
this is a real guy so like who he chose
to
like go professional with is a really
big look for aj it's a
big big get for aj this is aj's first
year as certified a lot of fun
a fun fact that i don't know a lot of
people who follow me don't realize is
that
aj was more in the position as me the
last
two and a half three years of vayner
just being the executive ceo like
running it
but uh this last year he decided to get
certified so
because a lot of the kids wanted to go
with him and
no no negativity to the agents we have
on our squad they just were more
connected to aj
and then would go other places because
they felt a little more connected to the
agent than
the agent that we had and so we just
thought there was an arbitrage there so
jay became certified
[Music]
three two one
one more three two one
thank you thank you guys thank you
[Applause]
thank you for the holiday
okay um if it's easier to stop at your
desk that's fine to do right here
thank you
that was a photo for uh the agency of
the year
oh best places to work
i don't know what it was but yeah we're
winning a lot of awards here at vayner
so
wow which one drock
which one
oh it's viral oh it's viral guys
actually quick question for dailyvee yes
yes what do you mean when you take a
weekly b
real quick because i know we're now
doing a whole new thing i'm sure caleb's
here going to use like
some quick little you know clips from
this uh this is my best friend brandon
who runs wine library yes he makes an
appearance in the vlog that makes me
happy
um you made an appearance in the sports
card episode too this is
as good as it gets it's [ __ ]
wednesday we sold 100
by the way weekly beef do not sign up
for wine text like caleb i want you to
like post produce like
cover my face here winetext.com now just
like i was saying to caleb maybe use
that clip
being signed up for me does not do me
any favors it costs us two cents or
something to send a text but if you buy
wine on the internet
if you buy wine on the internet and you
consume my content which is free
and you like me in any shape or form
it is massively important to me that you
signed up for wine text it is literally
the single best way to buy wine
um what were you asking for the weekly v
big nose when you say there's a big nose
on this
aromatically has a
massive nose like you can smell you can
smell stuff
like you can like here smell this you
can smell
like and and so like what you're just
smelling one wine right now but if we
had 50 wines here and you smell them all
some have huge aromatics some don't no
different than a deodorant
think of deodorant if you went to the
store right now and you know some
deodorants you just open
and like it's super aromatic you can
smell a lot and some just seem
kind of chill especially the new [ __ ]
like you know super like healthy [ __ ]
that's what i mean
it punches you in the face perfume some
is subtle something's over the top
big nose uh is
is the cmo on a call right now with
andrea yes okay i need to be on that
so everybody needs to wait what was your
plan that wasn't gonna be my plan was
this you can take 10 minutes and you're
gonna go down
no no no i mean she's already on the
call i get it
okay amazing thank you thank you
thank you so much
quick just one thing i noticed you went
from i have no idea what the meeting was
before but it was something obviously
completely different and then you just
very quickly went into that phone call
into like a total mode of like like
sales but in like a
i don't know it just seemed it's just
interesting and i think like people
watching are probably curious like how
you go from that switch
so fast yeah i think i think i'm very
good at putting things in compartments
like and i'm very quick like i have a
lot of things in my head and i'm
able to transition uh into the context
of tone and tender and you're right and
i think
what we should challenge ourselves to do
i would have um
andrea or or nick or marcus
watch that video right now and i think
you should beep out 37 things but i
think we should show people that because
i don't think people
understand there's that version of me
too and i think that could bring you
guys a lot of value and i think
you know we need to challenge ourselves
with weeklyv to be this new great thing
and i think one of the ways to do
is to show you more but it's going to
require me to beep 27 or 40 words just
now so you don't know who that was or
what
or their names or things that nature but
you can see what i'm about
the reason i reached out and thank you
so much for being so responsive is
you know andre and i always kind of like
as you can imagine you've been around
the block anytime you have
nice conversations or good vibes or
value somebody
you're it's always circling in our world
on the on
as a client service provider of like is
you know
okay is there ever a time to have a
conversation with that potential
client again how do and i think what's
helped us build something
meaningful is i think we're less pants
on fire we try to
reach out if we ever reach out because
we shortly know that they'll reach out
if they've
thinking about us if we have something
to offer and i think
we've had a really big breakthrough at
vaynermedia uh you know we have
super bowl spots so our aor creative
work is exploding our media business
is getting close to a dollars in spend
but 2019 was a year where we realized a
ton of people
wanted to work with us but the politics
of
you know first of all we are a shop that
does media creative under one roof
which as you know as a pro already is an
interesting dynamic because usually that
means two agencies in the
sandbox are being um you know
it touches their worlds and then and
then number two
you know and kind of what i think hurt
us a little bit with
we're doing ad hoc you know proposals
going back to ad hoc proposal there's
like
a one a five and a ten million dollar
fee uh sphere
that ends up you know maybe causing
sticker shock or things in this nature
and then that's one micro example there
was 150 examples of
ad hoc scope work that just didn't work
so we created uh we went to ces
this week and literally created more new
business
booked revenue in the first week of the
year than we did all of last year
and and now you think yes thank you and
here's how
we've made it very clear to people that
our creative strategy product
is a person team that starts at
v and that can be creative and social
aor or that can be your aor
and then why i'm really calling you
because i'm not necessarily intuitively
feeling that's the world we're talking
about
we created seven consulting products
what we call side dishes that are like
our products that we deem internally as
steal our brains and build it internally
or give it to the
agencies you work with and that our
thinking is so progressive and so right
that that in itself has karma points or
becomes
legit in the future and i i have always
felt like great vibes
towards you and recognized without us
really talking that
you know just by the action it's like
okay it's not it doesn't fit just this
yet
but i'm unbelievably excited about
uh some of the consulting products we've
created and i can see based on your
business from afar and just being crafty
that two or three might be valuable
um and i wanted you to be educated about
them so that was that's really the uh
context
okay so that phone call uh i happen to
be on the other
end of the the call with the client and
all i can say is that gary is
such a master at being on the move and
getting right to the point
and understanding where a client is
immediately
um and then the other great thing is
that he hands it off to the rest of us
to
to kind of bring it home if you will so
he sets things up he engages with people
in very real ways you can tell that he's
a human being first
there are no ceos that can run at the
pace that he does
but to connect um as a real human being
and that's why i love working with them
that's why all of us love working with
them and that's frankly why our clients
love working with them too
i think the other thing is that he's
just the master of all marketing
he talked about the way that we're
starting to productize
a lot of our the things that we're doing
in the consulting world and that's
because of his background he loves to as
he says put things in containers
um we even have a menu now that's uh
you know that sort of celebrates a new
jersey style approach to consulting who
has that
um but yeah it's really great to be um
to be alongside him and innovating every
day
and learning from him in all kinds of
[Music]
ways
[Music]
you know what i mean i like things that
come easy
i actually do it's a very back to like
it's this is why i think i talk so much
about strengths
i like the things that come easy to me
for most people they're not a robot and
can work 22 hours in a day like i did
yesterday
like and by the way i think everyone
should sleep seven eight and nine hours
yesterday serendipitously because i went
to national championship game and you
gotta go with the [ __ ]
champion lsu players to the club if
you're in the sports representation
business
you're [ __ ] in this business and like
and then my alarm didn't go off and like
[ __ ] all sorts of [ __ ] happened today
punchline is most people can't do that i
have natural energy
so i'm leaning into my natural energy
some people are pretty
dustin like i don't know how that being
a pretty life is but you know the
advantages of that
i'm talking about hey guys i'm dustin
uh the one that gary was talking to
during the podcast
gary likes to really involve his
whoever's with him pretty much recording
into his content a lot of times
but i'm also trying to coordinate a
podcast
which is live and i'm in my own little
zone
and when he catches me off guard so this
time it was uh
really caught me off guard because i
thought he was looking at me to say
something serious and then
he said some weird joke about my looks
right yeah no but really i really think
in wrapping this up there's no way
look there's a i do i believe that
people are listening who are gonna be
like i'm gonna do that too i do not
believe that everyone was given the same
group of talents i do think that we
should all
challenge ourselves to be self-aware and
try to figure out
the talents and then if we're lucky that
those talents
match something we're interested in
doing we have to go pot committed to
that
[Music]
what's today it was tuesday
[Music]
what up vlog 7 17 in the morning
the moon's out like what and i'm on my
way
big [ __ ] one say what's it big
[ __ ] wednesday
uh you're asking me what i'm doing right
now i'm sitting on the
line waiting for a very senior executive
from a potential client
uh i have to give them some sensitive
information
so i usually like to deliver that myself
in verbal form not in written form
context gets lost on email and text so
to me face to face is number one voice
is number two
when i have to give a contextual piece
of information
that could either be very exciting
potentially negative
i think people underestimate the seven
minute call in a 2020 environment
and use technology to uh
disguise themselves from a conversation
they don't actually want to have which
sometimes compounds a double negative
because the context of the bad news is
lost
in the text
[Music]
come on uh i got to be in the zone thank
you though
i also don't like how the split screens
are doing performing wise
i think we ought to test them hello
wooden swinging is doing now
ep video for the most part for like a
year or two stayed in a pocket
whereas right now back-to-back videos
could be like 1.2 million and the next
one could be 200 000. it makes me feel
like they're doing a better job
you know like i don't like when
everything's in the same pocket that
just feels like you know
like i would love the algorithms to get
wildly tight
give me four million when i deserve it
give me 40 000 when i don't
doing the right thing is always the
right thing yeah but i learned like i
said obviously
you know for me you're doing you're
doing you're doing strategic spec
work i do it all the time i get paid 200
000
to give a speech if somebody calls me
right now and says can you speak
in alabama let alone the javits center
and i like the audience and i think it's
worth it
i do it every day of course people are
too literal
everyone's transactional what you what
you're doing what i'm doing
maybe we have the advantages of coming
from very low places and
you know don't value our theoretical
time or energy
like other i don't know what it is but
it's very clear to me
that the biggest things are people that
are thinking three we're playing chess
everybody else is playing checkers uh so
we had a holiday party he helped us
produce it we bartered uh
i was gonna jam with him at the party
but i got caught up with something and
so
i just needed to deliver on what i said
which is if you do this for us
and produce this 10 year holiday party
i'll spend some time and like
really jam with you and like that's what
we did
[Music]
i gotta go fast drock i'm not not smile
hello it's gary how are you
so there's this guy dude would sign you
know
posting little like homeless sign kind
of photos
on his instagram you know going pretty
viral and stuff and like one of the
things that we like to do here on the
team
is you know find these trending moments
identify them
and find ways that we can you know give
our fresh take on it
so as you can see here we kind of had
gary doing you know his whole spiel
holding up the sign
and this post like dramatically just
like
destroyed and crushed it on instagram
our best performing post
of all time 750k likes um
before that the i think the the max
likes was like 300 and
370k or something like that like a nipsy
photo or something like that
and this just like destroyed it as you
can see
i'm like over here you know working
super hard on
coming up with like quote images for you
guys and you know
nothing i'm going to do is ever going to
beat that so you know i'm kind of
defeated a little bit but it's all good
but yeah it was a great post we had a
blast doing it
if you guys got any more ideas of things
like that that we should do please let
us know
drop it in the comments and yeah that's
about it
so i'm here with my homies caleb drock
jason behind the camera
lou aka frank um we're waiting on gary
right now to get out of a
uh a meeting um we're gonna film
or we're gonna take basically three
pieces of content three pieces of stills
and an intro for this in hopefully under
90 seconds four
we're gonna squeeze it in because gary's
leaving after this and he's not coming
back today
he's flying to vegas so we're gonna try
to squeeze it in we'll see what happens
you look good on camera i know
[Music]
be careful
[Music]
find out on this weekly v
cool see ya
okay i'll check you
holy [ __ ] somehow we just acquired like
two three maybe four pieces of content
in a matter of like 30 seconds real
quick before gary had to run to another
meeting
david rock [ __ ] crushed it jason
crushed it john crushed it
lou crushed it we'll see if i crushed it
today's friday i'm in vegas about to
give a speech to the hearing
aid industry believe it or not um
um and we're about to launch the first
weekly
which was last week which i'm excited
about
uh we recorded yesterday's first shot
show
called um uh interrupted by garyvee
which i'm excited
um and uh and i'm sorry i'm listening to
this guy
reinforcing um vlog i've been really
enjoying this process
um are you editing this one awesome
there's information so there's been some
good content this week yesterday i
didn't i should have done a selfie video
on the planet
anyway that's what we got blog um we're
really hacking at this we're really
passionate to bring you value
um and hopefully we will continue to do
that we're
three four minutes away from the talk
what i do in talks
is really think about who the audience
is and i reverse engineer it
i have a huge advantage because i've
grown up in retail i've worked in
you know smb small business kind of
entrepreneur land
i've worked for the last 10 decade 10
years with you know fortune 500
companies i've worked in silicon valley
global i read comments so
one of the things that really works for
me is i talk about the state of the
union of the world
and then i filter it through the context
and so that excites me
thank you thank you
my friends linkedin right this second
right this second as we sit here today i
am a day trader of attention
i like vine when vine's big i like
snapchat when snapchat's big
i like tick tock when tick tock's big i
didn't talk about linkedin
at all now i talk about it every day all
i do is look where there's an arbitrage
right this second
linkedin the platform that you think is
just your business profile
has become a content platform and it is
acting like facebook did in 2011.
there's a stunning amount of people on
it if you've been to your linkedin
recently and if you haven't please do
the content is no longer just business
it is absolutely everything
people's opinions what they're eating
exercise tips why
it has become facebook
the organic reach meaning you don't even
have a linkedin account
you start an account for your retail
store for your store forget about you
for your store
and you start posting content and people
will see it
without you paying for them to see it
because
it's just supply and demand the
attention on the platform
is greater than the content that people
are making
the biggest mistake that people make
when it comes to marketing
is they decide a platform is not for
them
you decide your customer's not on there
you decide
that tick tock is not for you right now
because that's for 12 to 15 year old
girls
and you're targeting 65 year old males
let's just say
what you don't understand is how
communication and marketing actually
works
which is if you're thoughtful enough
about the content you make
and you make a sweet little funny video
of a 15 year old
and a grandpa interacting it can bring
awareness for you
the lack of creativity or thoughtfulness
or understanding of human behavior
has led so many to not innovate or
execute
the costs are remarkably low
linkedin scares me how inexpensive it is
but are you the kind of organization
that is willing to make seven pieces of
content for linkedin a day
half this room doesn't make seven pieces
of content for social media
a year they take whatever this
organization sends them and they just
post it and think something's gonna
happen
my friends i don't know what you're
thinking but no matter how remarkable
this three generation family business is
that makes the best
products if you are not paying attention
to what technology is doing
to your industry you're putting your
head in the sand and you're going to let
a tidal wave run you over
period the world is not going backwards
technology and innovation doesn't care
about how you want it to be
you must become a practitioner
in communications because what the
internet is doing my friends
it is commoditizing everything but the
ability to communicate don't get it
twisted
it's happened and how you want it to be
isn't gonna change that thank you
[Music]
for two what's good bro
[Music]
you can um
go yesterday
listen when i talk about kindness being
the foundation
of business success a lot of people in
the comment section dms hit me up with
the concept of
gary you're wrong i'm so kind and people
walk all over me
this is a shout out this is a call of
action
this is a question to the humans that
say
you're wrong i always get walked all
over i
want to ask you a simple question when
you perceive
that you're giving is that you giving
something with the expectation that
something happens
like are you like grabbing tyler's
coffee every day but really what you
want him to do is promote you
and when he doesn't you're like oh i
didn't ask you to get that coffee on the
way
were you doing something kind
because you expected something in return
that
in the english language is called
manipulation
kindness giving is giving
and being kind with zero
double zero expectations
in return can i share a quick thought
with you
i don't know if it's an original thought
nice to meet you that's right
it's an original thought because it
comes from your filter as long as it
hadn't been said by someone else yeah
yeah but the angle it comes from i
actually think all thoughts are original
for that nature so
let's go ahead knowledge is learned but
wisdom is earned
yeah i understand that's something
punchline being
experience [ __ ] matters exactly like
i i was
you know it's funny i'm just facetiming
a football player my brother and i have
a sports representation business
when i was 22 and you heard my story on
stage right now i was a whiz kid it's
real
i had it i was an entrepreneurial talent
the 44 year old version of me right now
shits on that kid
and i thought that kid was unstoppable
right right so yes
experience matters however raw talent is
raw talent
mia 22 destroys tons of 44 year olds who
have plenty of experience
they just don't have as much talent as i
did and they don't put it into action
which is part of the talent execution of
business when you thank a soldier
for service yes it's your knowledge that
what they're doing is dangerous
yeah that they didn't have to do it yes
but you never walked in those boots
so that's the wisdom of course they have
the wisdom and you have the knowledge
that it's dangerous
like for example when i thank someone
that's more gratitude of the
acknowledgement
of what that's enabling me to do right
right
that's right which is the same way i
think about my talents have enabled
thousands hundreds of hundreds of
thousands of people of a shift of
mindset
tens of thousands of people in economic
earnings like you know we all play our
parts
yeah everyone plays their parts in
society rod stewart said hey i wish i
knew
what i know now when i was younger
everybody wishes that but
knowledge is learned and wisdom is
earned it kind of i'll be honest with
you
i'm unemotional about how the variations
of sentences or sayings are called you
know
to me i'm more worried about people
living it right right right
yeah you gotta get him to think about it
first well you've been 100 today
because i do a lot of our social media
and i've been trying to move our company
into that world and everything you said
today i was like see
take care stay well
[Music]
going to a meeting with a potential
client one of the big hotel groups here
in vegas
um and i'm excited that weekly b is
showing more
parts of that dynamic going from a
dynamic meeting around
esports and the minnesota rocker team
and hang out with some of the
you know players in the esports
landscape to boom get in the cab
get over to a top executive to
see if there's some business for boehner
x that's the gallery media group purewow
137 pm
or vaynermedia or the sasha group or
tracer
like living that vayner x yo so
i don't know if you guys remember
airport gary's but he's back on weekly v
we're wrapping up today's episode
just had a great meeting with a bunch of
senior executives at a very large hotel
group
here at the airport in vegas nice
sunshine in the background jason and i
jason and i did it we had a nice little
trip
you know drock no caleb it's jason and i
and uh just a good week i hope you guys
enjoyed the episode a lot going on
i also threw this banana what's good bro
just threw this banana on the ground you
see that banana i tried to throw it
from where i was before into there but
it missed so
leaving bananas in the [ __ ] streets
[Music]
his rock paper scissors shoot rock paper
scissors shoot
yup all right rock paper scissors shoot
rock paper scissors shoot
[Music]
the first line of the book is
i started thinking about my hands that
was my first mistake
boom you're in man you're in you're
[ __ ] in i'm in
i'm in you you're you said boom you're
in a little too fast you waited a 100th
of a beat i would have been more in
is that what she asked yeah remarkable
that was so cool
alex you know what just happened yeah
i just asked him to turn on the lights
without knowing you did
yeah this is wednesday
i'm sorry i was really creative you
hearing this jam
that britney spears [ __ ] baby brittany's
always back [ __ ]
okay by the way real quick by the way
real quick
if you didn't know what that reference
was you're fired
if you don't follow me on tick tock [ __ ]
you eitan
jared and i are here i don't know why
the [ __ ] you're not tell them something
what's up brother i'll hit you soon so
this thousand just came for
um uh just sat down and played war
um which is a highly skilled game in the
casino if you don't know
walking for my talk want a quick 700 it
was when i felt it and put 500 when i
got down
after i got up and down i got an ace
that was it tyler
yeah i got a little excited for a second
there's been i mean
yeah jake levy just got up he was
molasses you know
yeah people people get faster
[Music]
yo you good wake up man
i did not say if you're if you are 67
year old rick in here
and you're listening and you're like
okay i'm going to let my niece
do that for us i did not say that rick
yes where are you rick
i've been talking to you the whole time
brother
i knew you were here rick i've been
looking at you for a [ __ ] decade rick
jason where are you jason
get up go to rick pick we we've been
talking about them for 10 years
people that follow my content i
legitimately use rick and sally
please jason faster rick has a question
i mean you're 25 years old jason